Welcome to Lesson Four. You've done a lot so far.
You created an app and a database, you added fields
and objects, and you connected them all with relationships. You
took the default UI and you modified it, created ports
and dashboards. Yeah, your app looks pretty snazzy right now,
but the underlying app just doesn't do quite enough yet.
Let's go back to the music festival with Samantha and
Andy and figure out what you need to do next.
>> So we've already talked a bit about
the planning and the business sides of the festival.
>> But then there's actually running the festival.
>> Right, because in my experience, there's a ton of things
that can and do go wrong, that usually get fixed immediately.
>> Yeah, like at a festival, there could be
broken microphones, blown speakers. Bands might be running late.
>> Right. And ideally, the solution to
these problems would be as automated as possible.
>> Yeah. And then
SalesForce, we would use things like workflows or
approval processes to solve these kinds of problems.